I've never been really much of a fan of
music videos and I think that's because
I sort of just like my music as music I
like to close my eyes and and focus on
what's happening sonically because
that's what music is it's something that
you hear so that means I can be totally
engrossed and in love with Beyonce's
latest album and not care at all about
the dozen videos that came out with it
but I don't know maybe I'm in the
minority here and the truth is that
despite music being an aural medium it's
long had an intimate relationship with
the visual so I want to talk about
perhaps the most iconic visual
supplement in the history of music but
before we talk about that
what about album covers in general these
days we perceive them as a kind of
visual statement like the album title or
the song names that help us situate the
tone or the feeling of what we're going
to hear the granted that it stays within
the dimension of a square the options
and styles are basically limitless but
in the beginning record packaging was
purely utilitarian the early 78 rpm
gramophone records were mostly outfitted
with brown paper or cardboard sleeves to
protect the recording it wasn't until
1938 when Columbia Records hired Alex
Stein Weiss as its very first art
director that the idea of cover art came
into existence against the plain or
traditional design of early covers Stein
Weiss's original eye catching art
initiated just a huge boom in sales and
the market followed as it always does
when something works record stores were
refigured so that instead of just seeing
the bindings like books on a shelf
consumers were encouraged to flip
through the covers this all points to
just how important the cover art was to
the marketing of the product and music
is a product it's a commodity that
people consume and since you can't buy
the band itself and since the music has
no spatial dimension the album cover
emerged as the stand-in for the Kamat
the to be purchased this explains the
rise of photography on album covers and
what's called the personality cover you
know one of those covers where it's just
a photograph of the band or musician
still pretty popular today a perfect
example of this personality cover can be
seen on the Beatles first album Please
Please Me look at those bright smiling
faces staring warmly into the camera
lens as Susan Sontag once brilliantly
said in its simplest form we have in a
photograph surrogate possession of a
cherished person or thing as their
career advanced the Beatles seemed to
become darkly aware of their status as
commodities perhaps nowhere more plainly
acknowledged than on the cover of their
fourth album aptly titled Beatles for
sale featuring another example of the
personality cover this time without the
warmth and the smiles by the time
sergeant Pepper's emerge the Beatles had
already begun challenging the
conventions of popular music and its
role in culture and this extended to the
album covers - first in Rubber Soul with
its distorted image and funky typeface
then with revolver for which they
employed their friend and artist klaus
voormann who did a kind of 1960s update
of Victorian illustrator Aubrey
Beardsley 'he's famous black ink
drawings in other words the beatles were
leaders in expanding and album covers
function from a marketing tool to a work
of art in its own right and that brings
us back to what is really the holy grail
of album covers the beatles sergeant
pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band a cover
that explicitly engages the audience in
so many ways in critiques and
interpretations in comparisons and
contrasts it's a cover that invites you
in a perfect example of this is the
immediate challenge to just identify who
all of these people are what do Indian
gurus Karl Marx and Bob Dylan all have
in common
the sergeant pepper's cover wants you to
ask questions like this now in one sense
of course these people just represent
the Beatles interests and influences
many of whom didn't make the fine
cut and yet by juxtaposing highbrow
artists and thinkers like Marx for
Aubrey Beardsley or George Bernard Shaw
or Dylan Thomas with pop icons like Bob
Dylan Marilyn Monroe Marlon Brando and
Shirley Temple the Beatles
signal the breakdown and mixing of high
and low culture that they themselves
exemplified more than any other artist
with Sergeant Pepper the Beatles were in
a posture of challenge challenging
everything they'd been up to that point
challenging the highbrow art critics to
abandon their exclusion of popular
culture challenging the listening public
to engage with something other than love
songs in the same four chords they were
even challenging the feelings of unity
that defined the Summer of Love
in 1967 delivering a suite of songs that
featured alienation and loss as much as
it did love and togetherness the album
cover echoes these challenges and adds
some of its own by using the technique
of photo montage which manipulates
photography's unique ability to depict
reality the Beatles blend and collapse
the values of a number of different
times and places by staging the scene as
a performance and an audience the band
challenges us to dwell on the function
of both indeed these considerations were
at the front of their minds as the
Beatles had only recently elected to
stop performing live after the mayhem of
Beatle mania began to diminish the
quality of the music while some accuse
them of leaving their fans behind the
sergeant pepper's cover suggests the
opposite that the decision to stop
touring was out of respect for their
fans not out of fear or contempt we
should also note that the designer of
this cover Peter Blake was a noted
pop artist a style that used aspects of
mass culture to bring attention to the
fuzzy lines between art advertising
news and all other forms of media the
pop artists wanted to get people to
think about the process and
manufacturing of art and how its
categorizations and hierarchies are
largely arbitrary Blake and the Beatles
designed the Sergeant Pepper cover as
both a piece of art and
a product inside its gatefold sleeve the
record had paper cutouts of the pepper
bands regalia adding to its consumer
kitsch value and yet it was also the
first album to display the lyrics on the
packaging encouraging Lister's to
interrogate the records intellectual
content as well the truth is of course
that music perhaps more prominently than
any other art form plays both parts as a
commodity and an aesthetic object and in
many ways the two functions are
inseparable
The Beatles knew this and maybe they
regretted it but they were self-aware
enough to see that it was inescapable
and if music had to be marketed and if
the visual was going to be the vehicle
of that John Paul George and Ringo were
going to be as playful here as they were
with everything else in the end this
photograph of photographs levels a
critique on representation itself to
show how music is mediated by the visual
the Beatles put themselves on this cover
three times once as the wax figures of
the moptop Beatles that they were once
as the fake pepper band in its bright
and eye catching glory and finally as
themselves pictured not on the cover of
their album but by the effects of that
cover in the minds of everyone who
looked at it the real Beatles can't be
represented this way not really not like
this or like this or like this the cover
of sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band points to the truth what the
Beatles themselves knew
that all music
is invisible hey everybody thanks for
watching if you are new to this channel
I want to introduce myself I'm Evan the
nerd writer I make weekly video essays
that come out on Wednesdays about art
and culture and philosophy and whatever
I find interesting that week politics
science I make this channel full-time
with your help on patreon so if you want
to keep this channel alive you want to
see more of the nerd writer click here
or in the description and pledge as
little as $1 per video everything
anything helps patreon is really my big
push here so I appreciate your help and
I'll see you guys next Wednesday